and my name haydee sing
h and latin de y and last name s s h
but from peru i know that the
comparison prices are here where he saw it was
good in peru the outlet is quite
expensive and well it is almost the same price
but we understand that for here for the usa it
is it  a little expensive we don't come from another
state where it cost more or less a little to
sit on the metro
it's not that cheap it's not that expensive they're
the most expensive
this is a mask
or it doesn't really affect their
pockets much when I'm looking they
just take anything
gasoline
well, actually, since we didn't get caught by a
drop in gasoline around here, well, we looked for
the nearest gasoline, we had no idea
that it was more expensive, but, well, it was
because of a coincidence, but if
we looked at how three dollars were on average, I
didn't remember exactly how much it was, of
course  If you are going to fill the tank or not,
I suppose that if it will be considered
a difference, not
Adrián Esparza and from the area he is still
here from Las Vegas that Galactic them
gasoline prices, well, they are a
little surprised because every day they
go higher, they go more expensive in more expensive
problems that, well, there are not in many
places,
so try to look for it, but if there are not
more, we have to act as it comes,
yes, because the situation is hard  We
don't know how long it will take to compose
this, it's something that came
[Music]
further back, your lady told me that the
attack with loneliness that we're going to
start the summer and the prices, well,
as always, something doesn't go up, but
now it's more exaggerated, more exaggerated and
this but let's hope that everything improves
and it's not going to affect this is the mask yes
yes of course well in fact yes vidorreta
that work is just beginning many
people are not working and well right
now we are just
beginning
and with this but
[Music]